As protesters
keep on
with the fight for freedom
in Iran, the hardline
government continues its crackdown.
And CNN just spoke to one of thousands
of brave demonstrators.
A man who barely escaped
death, barely
managed to escape the country
with bullet fragments
still lodged inside him.
Yet he is vowing to return and fight on.
CNN's Jomana Karasheh has the exclusive.
And we want to warn you,
some of the images you'll see are graphic
It was one of the most terrifying videos
to emerge from Iran.
A protester surrounded by armed
regime forces
trying to send them off with a knife
Shots are fired
before he falls to his knees.
That's the latest
to talk to us more ashcan what he wants.
He later appeared in intensive
care,
barely conscious
with his parents by his side.
2002 so young.
I had a severed artery in my leg.
I had around 200 shotgun
pellets in my body.
I had serious wounds
even after I surrendered.
And they arrested me.
They beat me around
100 times in the head
and the rest of my body with batons.
When they were transporting me
to the hospital,
they shot me from a very close range
with a shotgun.
They thought that I'll be dead.
More of them. But Ashkan survived.
And with him,
a tale of unimaginable horror.
I don't think money.
I was the man who died
and was brought back to life
as I am speaking with you.
I still have 20 shotgun pellets
still lodged in my body.
He escaped Iran
Now a wanted man in hiding.
Speaking exclusively
to CNN for his safety.
He won't say where he is. Won't be easy.
I got out of the country
through mountains and deserts
while heavily bleeding and in very,
very bad condition.
I died so many times
before I got out of the country.
As he lay in hospital
hanging on to life
by a thread,
he was charged with Mahavir
waging war against God,
a crime punishable by
death in the Islamic Republic
regime.
Agents raided this hospital and dragged
Ashkan to jail.
As always,
when someone is taken
from the ICU straight to prison,
this is kind of a death sentence
in prison.
I went through unbearable agony
because all my wounds were open.
I used salt to try to disinfect my wounds
just a little bit.
They badly tormented me.
They sent me to an army hospital
that was not equipped to treat me.
I was there in that condition
with both my hands and feet
chained to the bed.
Every day.
People of his Kurdish town
of Shenandoah protested for his release.
His family paid
all they have to bail him out
for medical treatment.
And with the help of friends,
he made it out of Iran.
I was a professional boxer, a fighter.
I was so eager about my future
and had a plan
to pursue this sport as a career.
But because my leg
and the rest of my body
has been severely injured,
I can't do that anymore.
Being away from my
family and all the pressure
that they have endured
because of me is mentally tormenting me.
I'm not feeling
okay physically
or mentally on my side and stuff.
What do you want the world to know
about what is happening inside
Iran right now?
Hey, y'all I'm sorry, man.
There are so many like me
who sadly gave their life,
but their voice didn't reach outside.
There are so many brave
girls and boys inside Iran
are only crying
is that we demand freedom and democracy
and want our women
to be equal to our men.
We shouted Woman life, freedom
And their response to us
is only bullet,
only torturing, raping prisoners.
I saw many young people.
16, 17 year olds get killed.
They killed so many.
They blinded so many.
I swear to God,
I can't sleep at night
thinking about those things.
Now that I'm lost, the
Ashkan remains undeterred.
Once he recovers,
he says he's ready to go back
and continue the fight for free.
Iran.
Each pressing one.
I have no regrets.
And I am proud of what I did.
I will give my life for my people,
for my Iran.
Not one time, but 100,000.
You don't need to
And Jomana Karadsheh
joins us now live from Istanbul.
I mean, it's remarkable
he was able to get out.
Can you
can you give us a broader
sense of what's happening
there on the ground?
With other protesters now?
Absolutely, Anderson.
I mean, we have to first mention
that we did reach out
to the Iranian government
for comment on our report
and on Ash Khan's case,
they did not respond
to CNN's requests for comment.
The protests have subsided
for the most part.
We are still seeing
some sporadic demonstrations
taking place, mostly
in parts of the country
that are home to the country's
Sunni minority.
And tonight,
we're getting reports
of some protests in the Kurdistan region.
But in other parts of the country,
the protest movement
has really been pushed underground.
And people will tell you it's
because of several factors.
The weather being one, it's
snowing, it's freezing.
You've also got
air pollution
that has shut down several cities.
But also the regime's ruthless response
to these demonstrations,
that brutal crackdown
has had a chilling effect.
You've got thousands
who've been arrested, hundreds
who've been killed,
including many children.
At least four protesters
have been executed.
Many others
facing the death penalty
after what rights groups say.
Are these fast tracked sham trials?
That has had a chilling effect.
But protesters in Iran
we have spoken to say this is not over.
They say it's far from over.
They're saying this is a pause
The grievances are still there.
They say the anger has increased
and it's a matter of time
before these countrywide protests resume.
They say
some are describing
the situation, Anderson,
as this raging fire
under the ashes right now.
Jomana Karadsheh, I appreciate it.
Thank you.